hey guys it's max today we are comparing
the brand new apple watch
se to the also new apple watch
series six which i've been using over
the weekend
now if you are trying to decide between
these two you obviously care about
prices and about getting the best bang
for your buck because the se
is less expensive so obviously you guys
know the main price differences but
we're going to talk about prices towards
the end and there's a few things
that we actually didn't realize until
getting ready for this video but the
price difference is actually
bigger than we initially saw and
expected so we're going to dive into
prices here at the
end but first let's go ahead and open up
the new
s e i'm going to pop open we'll cover
now interesting the se has this little
wax paper
cover instead of the cardboard which
just actually comes off
a lot easier and this se is a 40 mil
model
because my son is probably going to be
wearing that with the family setup if
you guys missed the video you guys can
check that out
of course we just have the charger
without the power brick now
most people have that let's open up our
little band
this is the budget one even though it
might look a little bit funny on my
wrist
keep in mind that the features are
identical so this is the silver model
you can also get the se
in gold or in space gray so if you
want to get one of the new colors such
as the red or you want to get the blue
one
or you even want to get a stainless
steel or a titanium model
you have to get the series six the se
just comes in those three colors
with that said you do still have the
ability to put
any watch band on the se so i just got
in
the brand new braided solo loop it's
supposed to come on friday for my
series six let's go ahead and pull this
thing out i
definitely like how this looks at least
online i haven't seen it in person
okay that feels a lot nicer than i
expected i knew i looked i liked how it
looked
but i wasn't expecting to feel so much
like a normal band
but having the elasticity am i saying
that right less to see
let's go ahead and swap this out since i
was really looking forward to this new
braided solo loop and i think this one
is gonna be very popular so it's great
that you can still get it with the se
before i compare the exteriors let's do
a quick test and
no it's too loose oh my goodness
um now man i checked the sizing using
apple's little print out
and it seemed like i ordered the right
one let's do a double check here
yeah the right in between eight or nine
for me if you guys could see that
i went with the nine and i wish i didn't
now i'm gonna have to return this and i
really don't want to
but i can't deal with it flopping around
so that definitely is a disappointment
so
go on the smaller side absolutely don't
if you're closer to one just take one
step down because this probably is going
to stretch
after a while just like other people are
saying now let's compare the exteriors
and obviously this one's smaller but
other than that they're identical if we
look at the left side
the speakers the little ports look
identical the right side the button the
microphone cut out
the crown looks identical my se does
have lte
because i want to set it up for my kid
my series six doesn't so that's why you
don't see that little line
but other than that they're the same now
let's compare the sensors
i have my watch band off let's flip
these and compare the sensors and we
definitely see
a difference so it looks like the se has
the design from the series
5 and the series 6 has a whole new
design we have
uh four led lights four sensors in the
center because it could do
blood oxygen sensing so that the se
can not do but the se also looks
different let me grab my other apple
watches
it's crazy i have five apple watches
here that's weird but let's start out
with
the series five and it's interesting to
see
that the centers are the same here but
the outside is different
just like on that series six we have
these two outside portions
a ring around it my series 5 also has it
but the se does not have that so that
has to be
for the ecg feature which the se
doesn't have let's add in the series 3
there's a huge difference here the
casing is much larger with just a little
central circle
and then we have some lights two lights
and then looks like two sensors
so it's definitely an upgrade from that
so now we know that the se
is just like the series four and the
series 5
just without the ecg now i also have my
series
0 original apple watch it's interesting
to see that the sensors are the same as
the series 3.
if you guys want to see a full
comparison between the se and the series
3 what you get for the
extra eighty dollars go ahead and click
that little subscribe button down below
enable those notifications
now let's get into the displays and
thankfully the se
is using the same display as the siri
six
that means if you're using a full screen
watch face
or if you have photos that are showing
up you get these nice
rounded corners and the screen size is
larger with slimmer bezels
than you would on a series 3 or an older
apple watch so that is great now the
display tech
is also the same it's using a ltpo
display
so that uses less power but with the se
you don't have the ability to have an
always on display so that's something
that apple
locks out just with software to you know
make a little bit of a difference there
so as you guys see with this watch face
we still have the always on the sc you
don't so you have to raise up your wrist
and then you see it just like with a lot
of the older apple watches
on a positive note you do still get all
of the same watch faces so here's the
typography watch face
so you're not limited in that along with
sharing the watch faces they
also share a ton of other features i
have a full list right here
they both have the same file detection
the same second generation heart rate
sensors
the same accelerometers they have uh the
same
speaker the same microphone the same 32
gigabytes of storage which i was
surprised by
the same w3 chip and the same bluetooth
5
and the series 5 actually shares that as
well
so it's kind of like a series 5 but
there's one thing that the se
gets from the series 6 that the 5
doesn't have and that's the always on
altimeter that means that the se along
with the six they can always tell
your altitude which is great if you're a
hiker that gives
more information for your workouts so
your watch will know
when you're going up in elevation they
can apply that to the calories you burn
and other aspects
which could be nice if you do a lot of
hiking so with so many of the same
features and specs what does the series
6
give you well the first one is the
ability to do ecgs
which will check your heart for
irregular heartbeats
the next one is blood oxygen sensing so
if you're somebody that could have some
health issues
or like my son he has asthma and
allergies
that could be really handy the seri six
has the new u1 chip that is included
with the new iphones
now one thing we know is it's gonna make
it a lot easier to find your watch if
you left it somewhere
but there's probably gonna be a lot more
features that go along with that that
we'll find out at next month's apple
event
the six is the first watch that can
connect to five gigahertz wi-fi
so it could give you some better range
and also some faster transfer speeds
for say you know music photos things
like that but i haven't really noticed
an issue
with mine and then along with that it
also has the s6
processor which is about 20 uh faster
let's do a quick test here see if we can
notice a difference
so as far as switching between watch
faces both are super smooth
let's go to our home page i have it set
up a little bit differently
but uh based on what i've been playing
around right now with the se
it seems plenty fast has the same
processor as the series 5 which is
already
a very fast processor now i will say
with my series 5
i did occasionally notice some glitches
sometimes when i'd go in to
adjust the watch you'd get a little
glitch in the animation that could be
once you're using the watch for a while
you have a bunch of apps on it you have
stuff running in the background
but it is not bad with the siri six i've
been using it over the weekend and it is
definitely a little bit smoother
so with all of that said let's get into
prices and then talk about
which one you should buy the base
starting price of the series 6
is 3.99 or 400 and the se is 279 so
that's a 120
difference and that is pretty
significant
now i did say at the start that the
prices get a little bit more
interesting it's a bigger difference
than you'd expect and that is because if
you're
buying one with lte the series six and
all the previous apple watches
apple would charge an extra 100 dollars
for that lte option so it was a pricey
upgrade
surprisingly and thankfully with the se
apple is only charging 50 more if you
want lte
so that brings the price difference to
170
dollars that is very significant and
you'll need the lte if you want to set
up
one for say your kid or a family member
you have to have the lte set up so with
that price difference being
so big you can actually buy an se you
can add on lte
even if you might not use it right away
you can upgrade to a different watch
band like the new solo braided loop
and you're still twenty dollars cheaper
than the very base model
basic apple watch series six so that is
a very impressive difference and gives
you a lot of value with the se
so with the ses value being so good
why would you spend the extra money on
the series six well there's just a few
reasons the first ones are if you have
health issues or if there's health
issues
in the family you want to have that ecg
ability
you want to have the blood oxygen
sensors that's going to be a no-brainer
to spend the extra money
and along with that if you want the
extra finishes say if you want to get a
stainless steel one
or you want to get the red or the blue
you have to get the series six apple is
locking that just for the higher end
models and then another one that's going
to be a big one for a lot of people is
the always on display
having the ability to see the time see
notifications and just have a little bit
of a nicer look
when the screen is off instead of having
it be purely black
that is going to be another big reason
but with that said i think for the vast
majority of people
the se just makes a ton of sense apple's
packing in a lot of value
it's almost like a series five that cost
way more last year
so let us know your thoughts and which
one you want to go with down in the
comment section below we're gonna have
links to both in the video description
a lot of times there's great deals on
amazon so make sure to go and check
those out
and if you want to see our full review
after we use these click that circle
above to subscribe
and if you want to set it up for your
kid we have a video for you as well
thank you for watching it's been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]